senate will come to order
the chaplain dr black will open the
senate with prayer
let us pray
great redeemer
guide our lawmakers along
the best path to fulfill
your purposes on earth
may they submit to your wisdom and
providential leading believing
that you will supply
all of their needs
remind them that your unfailing
love accompanies those
who put their trust in you
lord give our senators
an attitude of reverential awe
that will keep them from evil
inspire them to rejoice
and be glad as they strive
to live lives of purity
and obedience and lord
as we remember pearl harbor
on this december 7th
thank you for your loving
and prevailing providence
may we show our gratitude by
facing the future without
fear we pray
in your majestic name
amen
could you please join me in the pledge
of allegiance
i pledge allegiance to plague of the
united states of america
and to the republic one nation under god
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
mr president senator from iowa one
minute for morning business without
objection
i want to visit with my colleagues about
something
that hasn't happened in iowa for over a
hundred years
over the weekend the iowa state football
team completed their regular
season play the cyclones are having a
noteworthy season they secured
the first place rank in the big 12
conference regular season
after winning five consecutive
conference games
and eight overall conference wins this
season
the good news it doesn't stop there for
the iowa state football
program the cyclones finished first
place
in the league play for the first time
since
1912 when they won the missouri valley
conference
this has earned the cyclones their
well-deserved spot
in the big 12 title game on december the
19th
the first ever big 12 championship
appearance
in iowa state university's history
i want to applaud the cyclones for their
historic season
so many fans including me will be
rooting them on for the big 12
championship game i yield the floor
the clerk will call the roll mr
alexander
you
you
the senator from vermont uh
mr president i ask consent to call the
quorum be dispensed with
without objection under the previous
order the leadership time is reserved
morning business is closed under the
previous order the senate will proceed
to executive session to resume
consideration of the following
nomination
which the clerk will report nomination
the judiciary stephen sidney schwartz of
virginia to be a
judge of the united states court of
federal claims
senator from vermont uh mr president i'm
speaking both as the senator from
vermont
and his vice chairman of the senate
appropriations committee
and speaking with a concern about what's
happening in the senate
it's been 321 days since the first covet
19 case was reported
in the united states 321 days
it's been 282 days
since the first covert 19 death was
reported
in the united states the bureau of labor
statistics reports that the unemployment
rate in november
was 6.7 percent nearly double the rate
in november of last year hundreds of
thousands of small businesses across the
country have closed permanently
all due to covet as of today
there are more than 14
million 800 000 reported
cases of covert 19 in the united states
to put that in perspective that's one
million more than just a week ago
more than 282 000 americans have died
and it's been 256 days since the senate
passed the cares act
256 days since the senate acted in a
comprehensive
meaningful way to address the real and
mounting concerns and needs of our
constituents
my state of vermont is like everywhere
else healthcare workers caregivers
business
owners employees teachers and students
all in need of support in these
difficult and uncertain times
we have families especially with
heightened food insecurity
people who for the first time in their
lives they can't feed their children
they can't feed themselves
they have the threat of eviction hanging
over them
we have states that are strapped by
budget shortfalls they're
forced to lay off thousands of employees
people work
so hard for the people of their state
it's been 205 days since the house
first passed the heroes act and it's
been 65 days since they stepped forward
to offer a substantial compromise on the
heroes act
and pass it again and where is it set
it sits on my friend the republican
leader's desk it's collecting dust as
the largest and most significant bill
in the mcconnell legislative graveyard
why aren't we voting look what happens
we can't bring ourselves actually vote
on something to help
americans help the people of our own
state
they're being thrown out of their houses
their their apartments and
off their jobs and we come in for a few
days
they can get on an airplane fly back
home taxpayers paying for it
taxpayers paying our our um
salaries and all and nothing
happens now
like millions of americans
i'm encouraged by the news in recent
weeks that pharmaceutical companies
are making significant progress in
vaccine development
i'm encouraged some of these vaccines
may be
available as early as later this month
but let's not forget why we're able to
develop vaccines so quickly
it's because of long-standing federal
investment and cutting-edge research
at the national institutes of health
research has been backed by so many of
us in both parties
for years in this body
nih funded research in genetic and
genomic
sequencing enabled the rapid and
efficient pivot
to cover 19 research that led to the
vaccine
this is the power of federal dollars
when it's targeted to solve a national
a national problem we need more of that
today
the development of several promised
vaccines is great news
but if you don't have a comprehensive
plan in place
and the resources to implement it how
can we ensure that vaccination is safe
effective widely available and free
can anybody stop and say every part of
their state
will have vaccination no the money's not
there yet we have nothing on that
and it's complete abdication of our
responsibility
as elected representatives that we
simply failed to act
now i know that uh my friends across the
aisle will probably rush to the floor
they'll blame democrats
for stalling their inadequate face
saving proposal
that they went through the motion to
bring before
the elections remember what it was
it was a giveaway to insurance companies
and didn't even have the courage
to allow amendments where people would
actually have to vote up or down
it's easier to make a face savings
gesture knowing it go anywhere sure it
made some
investment in small businesses it
provides some employment relief
albeit at a significantly reduced level
but also tied educational relief to
forcing kids back into the classroom
even if it's an area where it wasn't
safe
to accommodate those children they
failed to deliver on relief to state and
local governments
which are continuing to try to provide
essential services
to their communities as our
as our government is in
in in vermont it included
nothing for low-income home energy
assistance
ly heap and it was snowing and i know
our state and a lot of other northern
states
this week had no funding for mental
health service
can you imagine can you imagine
what's going on no funding for mental
health service
there's no funding for nutrition
assistance there wasn't a
dime for nih research it didn't
have a plan a vigorous plan or
investment
in vaccination production and
distribution
it's one thing i said we oh we have
these super cold
things on an airplane wonderful
when are you going to be able to bring
it to our factories our schools our
hospitals
our senior citizens that actually
vaccinate them
so what was the legislation
brought up here it created a shield for
corporate misconduct
and when it said that my friends the
republicans are more keen to shield
corporate cronies
than to work on behalf of the american
people that's a sham
it's a shame
especially when they find at least one
of those corporations they want to
shield
they were betting on who
would get covered first the managers
were
now in my home state of vermont
our governor our state legislature our
mayors our town leaders across the state
have taken bold moves to slow the spread
of covet
my governor is a republican i'm a
democrat i praise him
for what he did i talked with him again
today
for the steps he's taken difficult steps
hard steps the steps to keep vermonters
safe
and these moves taken in my state of
vermont
they've resulted in lower instances of
the virus
than anywhere else in the country
but as the governor said
i've said everybody else said they've
come with a cost
we've kept people safe but not without a
cost
unemployment remains small businesses
continue to struggle if they're even
able to stay in existence
and that says nothing of the personal
hardship families are facing across our
small state
one elderly woman called my office
she expressed frustration with the
president she told my staff that she's
only been able to visit her husband
who was in a medical rehab facility a
couple of times
during this pandemic due to covert
restrictions
now that's not an anecdote that's a
personal
tragedy in vermont the state and local
governments are worrying about how to
clear the road this winter
if covert hits a plow cruise
snow removal isn't a luxury in vermont
in the winter it's a
necessity
and we sometimes have seven eight nine
ten inches of snow overnight
but we expect our businesses and our
schools to open
that day i don't know how many times
at home on a snowy night
i'm awakened at 4 30 in the mornings i
hear the snow plows going by on the road
and i know i can get to my office a
couple hours later
and we've had nearly a foot of snow
my staff spoke with one vermont mother
not unusual she's raising
a son with autism with school systems
trained to their limits special
education
services have been sharply reduced
that's going to have a lasting impact on
these students
both educationally and socially
and for those who are facing challenges
like addiction
depression or mental health issues
and that could be any one of our states
we're simply down there like before
covert earlier this year
access to vital resources counseling
intervention has been made more
complicated by covert restrictions
often with tragic results i heard of one
vermonter who
passed away alone in a motel room
in rutland in october barely mental
health issues he had become homeless
just as clovis struck earlier this year
and due to the risks of the virus family
and friends were unable
to take them into their homes this isn't
just a story it's a man's life
and there are so many more people out
there facing the same struggles
we're seeing images of car lines of food
banks stretching for miles
unprecedented wave of food insecurity
washing over our country
in our state my state alone one in every
four
vermonters now food insecure
before this pandemic is already an
unacceptable one in ten
we're asking children to learn without
providing the necessary resources their
teachers their families to pay rent
without their job
and people deal with their chronic
illnesses
while our hospitals are still stretched
to capacity
all this while an unacceptable amount of
people are unsure
how they'll put food on the table
to the end of the week in the wealthiest
nation on earth
that's unconscionable and i must say
that the leadership across the aisle
they've got to bring up
these bills stop stalling you know
they say we only need a targeted
approach and they point to the stock
market as proof
these people are their jobs i look at
the stock market these people
who can't feed their children look at
the stock market these people
whose rent is coming due and they can't
pay it to them that's nonsense
the economy is not going to recover
until we vanquish the virus it's that
simple is that basic and people are
suffering now
that's the cost of inaction inaction on
real comprehensive
bold covert relief legislation
and so now that backs against the wall
with a funding deadline looming we're
racing to accomplish what should have
been done months ago annual
appropriations bills to keep our
government running
we were ready on this side of the aisle
to vote on those back in june
have a couple of amendments up or down
republicans in the majority if they
didn't like the democratic amendment
they could vote it down
we could have done it back then now
deadlines this week months later
we have to pass these bills before
congress adjourns this year
so there's no disruption in our
government services during this
difficult time in our country
that only exacerbate the growing
problems facing many americans today
but our annual appropriations bills are
no substitute for the significant
investment we need to confront this
national
and international emergency we need a
comprehensive covert relief bill
it's time to take to get serious instead
of flying off every weekend
back home stay here vote these things up
or down
bring up amendments on both sides of the
aisle time agreement on the amendments
and vote them
up or down because time is wasting
and how many hours have we spent racing
to confirm nomination
after nomination at the expense of
everything else
including dealing with the emergency of
this pandemic
while colvin cases soar and more and
more people succumb to this virus
how much more time will the senate waste
while american families and communities
suffer
it's time for us to do our job we're
elected for six year terms
let's stay here for six days during the
week if need be
let's get it done the american people
are suffering enough
we shouldn't be adding to that strain by
playing politics for these essential
priorities
and i'm president i'm hearing from
vermonters every day
worried about unemployment benefits
their children's education
their health or their their loved ones
about food security about keeping their
homes
and paying their bills the senate when
it's been
at its best has been the conscience of
the nation
it's long past time we start acting
like the conscience of the nation 256
days
since the senate took meaningful action
on this covet epidemic we shouldn't wait
a day longer
let's set everything else aside let's
have votes on these programs
let's vote up or down the senator is
ready to do that
and i see the distinguished leader on
the floor
and i yield the floor
senator from missouri madam president in
recognition of his outstanding service
to my office this last year i ask
unanimous consent
that captain ryan alban the defense
fellow in my office be granted floor
privileges
for the remainder of this congress
without objection i yield before
madam president the majority leader
we've reached the time of year when the
senate has
more important outstanding business than
we have days to complete it
delivering for the american people will
take focus
dexterity and genuine bipartisanship
on government funding as i've said for
weeks it's my hope that our committee's
work will bear fruit and a full
year funding package will come to the
floor
in both chambers i anticipate that the
senate will take up a one-week extension
this week so the government does not
close on december the 11th
and work can continue through the end
of next week the nation needs our
democratic colleagues to resist the
temptation to play brinksmanship with
long subtle policy issues
or push poison pill riders that they
know
would tank the process we
also expect to receive and pass a
conference report on the annual defense
authorization
and we need to continue confirming
impressive nominees to vacancies
in the judiciary and the executive
branch
we senators are no strangers to the year
of the end-of-year drama
by this time this time mistakes are far
higher
we're up against another even steeper
surge in covet 19
than we saw back in the spring workers
in small businesses are once again
struggling to make ends meet at states
and localities
step up precautions and while the latest
news on vaccine trials suggests
that victory over the virus may soon be
within reach
our work in that area is far from
complete
as one recent article put it state and
local officials plead for vaccine
distribution
funds our nation's historic sprint to
victory
through vaccines seems poised to succeed
in record time
but the critical last step getting
hundreds of millions of doses out to
american people
is still in front of us so congress
cannot stay on the sidelines
now yesterday our colleague from
illinois the democratic whip gave an
interview in which he named three
examples of highly urgent matters that
need to be addressed for our nation
right now is the democratic
whip of the u.s senate here are the
three things senator durbin mentioned
as flashing red urgent priorities
the millions of people who are going to
lose their unemployment insurance the
day after christmas
the businesses that are trying to decide
whether or not
they can continue and the vaccine
logistics to make sure that this vaccine
is on the road
and vaccinating people across america as
quickly
as possible those are the three things
he mentioned
those are the three urgent issues he
named as examples
ending unemployment extending
unemployment insurance helping small
businesses and funding vaccine
distribution
well madam president i do not question
the sincerity of our colleague
who i believe is engaged in these
discussions in good faith
but these comments illustrate perfectly
a point that republicans have been
making for weeks
or weeks these three urgent issues are
issues where there is
almost total bipartisan consensus no
real disagreement whatsoever
in fact the framework for a small
targeted relief package that i put
forward last week
something which democrats quickly
attacked
would have resolved all three of those
subjects
all three of them the targeted
republican framework extends
unemployment insurance programs that
will otherwise expire
it creates an entire second round of the
paycheck protection program
for the hardest hit small businesses and
it lays the groundwork to distribute the
vaccines that appear to be on the
horizon
check check check
democratic whip is right to recognize
these three subjects are especially
urgent because
they are especially urgent
that's why republicans have been trying
over and over to get them passed
that's why republicans have been saying
for months
that speaker pelosi and the democratic
leader should let congress get outcomes
in all the places where we already agree
where we already agree rather than
holding everything hostage
over their most controversial partisan
demands but month
after month after month
it is the democratic leaders who have
said that no relief whatsoever can pass
no consensus items can become law
unless multiple contra controversial
areas where we don't agree
are resolved to the democrats liking
that's why the democratic leader had
every single senate democrat vote to
filibuster
a targeted covet 19 release package back
in september
and again in october that bill would
have taken care of small businesses
unemployment insurance and vaccine
distribution
months ago months ago
senate democrats blocked it
well i think if the senate democratic
leader would allow it the three things
that the democratic whip
mentioned just yesterday small business
aid
re-upping unemployment aid and setting
up vaccine distribution
would pass the senate in a landslide
in a landslide a targeted compromise on
the most urgent items would pass by a
massive
bipartisan margin we could easily put
together a whole slew of common sense
policies including those three and other
things like
legal protections at universities and
the council
american council on education have been
pleading for
bring it to the floor and pass it
everyone knows why this hasn't happened
there's one reason the speaker of the
house and the democratic leader has
spent months trying the most bipartisan
tying the most bipartisan common sense
policies
to their most controversial request
and saying the country can't get the
former unless it gets the latter
their strategy has been all or nothing
and so struggling americans
have of course got nothing well we're
down to the wire
madam president down to the wire
the light at the end of the tunnel is in
sight
operation warp speed seems poised to
deliver vaccines on
an historic almost miraculous timetable
we have seen some hopeful signs of
engagement from our democratic
colleagues
but we have no reason to think the
underlying disagreements about policy
are going to
evaporate overnight
republicans and democrats do not need to
resolve every one of our differences to
get badly needed relief
out the door we just need both sides to
finally do what members of congress do
when they're serious
when they're serious about wanting an
outcome
drop the all or nothing tactics
drop the hostage taking and make law
in the many places where we have common
ground
that's what the country is counting on
that's how we can do right by the
american people before christmas
so let's get it done
madam president i move to proceed to
legislative session
question is on the motion all in favor
say aye
aye all the pilots know
the eyes appear to have it the eyes do
have it
motion is agreed to i'll move to proceed
to executive session to consider
calendar number 912.
the question is on the motion all in
favor say aye
aye all opposed no
the eyes appear to have it the eyes do
have it
the motion is agreed to the clerk will
report the nomination
nomination federal election commission
alan dickerson
of the district of columbia to be a
member i'll send a closure motion to the
desk
the clerk will report cloture motion we
the undersigned senators in accordance
with the provisions of rule 22 of the
standing rules of the senate do hereby
move to bring to a close
debate on the nomination of alan
dickerson of the district of columbia to
be a member of the federal election
commission signed by 17 senators as
follows
as the reading on the names we waived
without objection i moved to proceed to
legislative session
the question is on the motion all in
favor say aye
aye all opposed no the eyes appear to
have it
the eyes do have it the motion is agreed
to
i moved to procedure executive session
to consider calendar 913
the question is on the motion all in
favor say aye
aye all opposed no the eyes appear to
have it
the eyes do have it the motion is agreed
to
the clerk will report the nomination
nomination federal election commission
shawna m broussard of louisiana to be a
member
i'll send a closure motion on the desk
the clerk will report
cloture motion we the undersigned
senators in accordance with the
provisions of rule 22 of the standing
rules of the senate
do hereby move to bring to a close
debate on the nomination of shauna m
broussard of louisiana to be a member of
the federal election commission
signed by 17 senators as follows senator
reid on as we wave
without objection i move to proceed to
legislative session the question is on
the motion
all in favor say aye aye all opposed no
the eyes appear to have it the eyes do
have it
the motion is agreed to i'll move to
pursuit executive session to consider
calendar 9-1-4
the question is on the motion all in
favor say aye
aye all opposed no the eyes appear to
have it
the eyes do have it and the motion is
agreed to
the clerk will report the nomination
nomination federal election commission
sean j
cooksey of missouri to be a member i
send a closure motion to desk
the clerk will report
cloture motion we the undersigned
senators in accordance with the
provisions of rule 22 of the standing
rules of the senate
do hereby move to bring to a close
debate on the nomination of sean j
cooksey of missouri to be a member of
the federal election commission
signed by 17 senators as follows i was
consent to read the nigeria
without objection as unanimous consent
the senate resume consideration of the
schwartz
nomination without objection
okay i'll suggest you perform the clerk
will call the roll
mr alexander
you
you
you
you
foreign
president democratically doing a quorum
we
ask unanimous consent the quorum be
dispensed with without objection
now madam president last night we
received the sad news that a former
colleague of ours one of our finest
paul sarbanes has passed away while our
time in the senate
only overlapped for one term senator
sarbanes made a deep impression
known as the stealth senator he was
low-key but extremely effective
a leader on a wide-ranging group of
issues from environmental stewardship
to consumer privacy to anything having
to do with his home state of maryland
he was very soft-spoken but he had
determination like iron
and worked and worked and worked on
issue after issue until he achieved his
goals
we mourn the passing of this beloved
former colleague
and this consummate senator
now on covet everyone knows we're
entering the worst stretch of the covet
19 pandemic
as the winter months force more
americans indoors
infections are up hospitalizations are
up
and the number of americans dying from
covet is steadily
and tragically increasing the economic
fallout from the latest wave of the
virus will also be a huge challenge
according to one study nearly 12 million
renters
will owe an average of nearly six
thousand dollars in back rents
and utilities in january even the
conservative u.s chamber of commerce
is sounding the alarm about a double-dip
recession
if congress does not pass another round
of emergency
federal relief before the end of the
year
unfortunately our efforts to pass
another emergency relief bill through
the senate
have been stalled until now for one
reason the republican leader
has refused to compromise again today
we heard the same old song from the
republican leader
his position has not budged since march
first he put the senate on pause while
the spread of the virus got worse and
worse
then after pressure mounted the
republican leader finally decided to put
forward a series of bills that
compromised
only the things that the republicans
want
while the nation has been clamoring for
a bipartisan solution
the senate under the leadership of the
republican leader
has only been allowed to vote on
partisan republican proposals
each of which has been sorely inadequate
and each of which
has contained poison pills designed to
ensure the bill's failure
the republican leader never mentions
those poison pills in his speeches to
this chamber
where he excoriates democrats for
refusing to pass quote bipartisan
legislation
that everyone agrees on but bipartisan
does not mean democrats must agree to
whatever the republican leader wants
or whatever issues he picks bipartisan
means both sides sitting down
finding an agreement we all know that's
the case
we have a democratic house they're going
to need democratic votes in the senate
so dem senate democrats are simply
asking the republican leader to do one
thing
sit down and negotiate now since
march since since secretary mnuchin and
i negotiated the cares bill
the republican leader has constantly
refused to sit down
with republicans and negotiate a
bipartisan solution
he puts his bill with no democratic
input on the floor
and says take it or leave it that is no
way
no way to get things done it wasn't
in april or may or june or july or
august or september or november and it
isn't now
speaker we want the leader to sit down
and negotiate
so we can come up with a bipartisan
proposal
that can pass both the house and the
senate
and speaker pelosi and i have modified
our proposal
several times in an effort to meet our
republican counterparts in the middle
last week speaker pelosi and i went even
further
and agreed to use a bipartisan bill
crafted by moderate senators from both
sides of the aisle
as a framework for the negotiations
we have not heard the same willingness
from the republican leader
however there are some encouraging signs
the bipartisan group of senators and
house members working on this latest
proposal continues to make progress
i was encouraged to see the senator from
louisiana this weekend say he was
hopeful
the president would sign such an
agreement let's use the work of the gang
of eight
as the basis for bipartisan negotiations
and compromise
the bottom line we have to get something
done for the american people before the
end of the year
we democrats have been trying since the
spring
back when republicans were saying quote
they did not feel the urgency of acting
i believe those were the leaders words
well
it's going to take a sense of urgency
now mister leader
and it's going to take a willingness to
give a little
not just to put your bill on the floor
and say take it or leave it
as as i said it's encouraging
that some republicans are already on
that path
hopefully the republican leader can
catch up
with the more fair-minded members of his
caucus
now on nominations another matter
the incoming biden administration
continues to name
candidates it will tap to lead cabinet
agencies and other key positions in the
federal government
today president-elect biden introduced
his healthcare team
including dr fauci who will stay on
thank god
as chief medical adviser dr vivek murthy
to serve as a
as surgeon general dr rochelle walensky
to head the cdc
and javier becerra the attorney general
of california
to be the next secretary of health and
human services
like most of president biden's elect
selection so far
mr pasera's nomination is groundbreaking
he would be the first latino to ever run
the department of health and human
services
now these nominees once confirmed will
face a monumental task
president-elect biden will inherit a
once-in-a-generation health care crisis
a crisis made worse by the trump
administration's lack of focus
competency and consistency over the past
year
by naming a deeply experienced and
tested team
of senior health care advisors
president-elect biden is getting ready
to right the ship
and execute a whole of government
approach to crushing the virus
and providing affordable health care to
all americans
a safe as safe and effective vaccines
become available over the next year
president-elect biden's team will also
have to work with states and health care
providers
to get americans vaccinated
to state the obvious health care is
going to be
the number one challenge when the new
administration takes office
we're in the middle of a once in a
century
public health crisis accordingly
president-elect biden's team should be
confirmed swiftly
to ensure that no time is lost in the
fight against the pandemic
regrettably there's a split screen this
week between the seriousness of the
incoming biden administration
and the activities of the republican
majority here in the senate
on tuesday the republican chairman of
the homeland security committee has
invited dr jane
orient to give testimony at a hearing in
his committee
dr orient is a member of the association
of american physicians and surgeons
a benign sounding name that obscures
some dangerous policies
according to the new york times dr
orient's association quote
opposes government involvement in
medicine and views federally
federal vaccine mandates as a violation
of human rights
unquote doctor orienteer herself
has expressed skepticism about
coronavirus vaccines
and continues to hawk hydro
hydroxychloroquine as covid19
treatment following the lead of
president trump
who boosted the drug despite scientific
evidence that it's ineffective
so while president biden is nominating
experienced
committed public servants to lead the
administration's health care policy the
next administration's health care policy
the republican majority is inviting
prominent anti-vaxxers
to senate committee hearings a study in
contrast
to say the least after one of the most
difficult years in recent memory
we finally have a light at the end of
the tunnel in the discovery of several
effective
and safe vaccines they're the best
chance we have
of ending the terrible scourge of this
disease and getting our lives back to
normal
and yet the effectiveness of the vaccine
only matters in insofar
as the number of americans who are
willing to take it
the more senate republicans dip their
toes into the water of these
anti-science
anti-backs conspiracy theories the more
damage it does to our country
public figures at all levels should be
building up confidence in a vaccine
not giving a platform to those who would
undermine it
the senator from wisconsin the chairman
of the homeland security committee
should revoke his invitation to dr
orient
i yield the floor
senator from texas madam president i
came to the floor to talk about some
other things but i just want to
say in response to our friend the
democratic leader
it sounds to me that he's got a case of
do as i say not as i do
when it comes to coven 19 relief bills
my memory if my memory serves me
correctly he has led the effort to block
the senate's consideration of five
different
covid 19 relief bills speaker pelosi has
made the incredible statement that
nothing
is better than something when it comes
to covet 19 relief
that's easy to say when you're still
getting a paycheck when you've got a job
you can go do
and you can provide for your family and
you have access to health care
but for the millions of americans who
suffered through this pandemic
those are words that sound a lot like
marie antoinette
let them eat cake
i mention this because i've been around
this place long enough to know that
unless you
tell people the whole story uh too often
they believe
the talking points and the half story of
the incomplete story
like we heard from the democratic leader
it is shameful
that after passing four separate coven
19 relief bills including the cares act
through the end of
march on virtually unanimous basis
that speaker pelosi chose to pass a
partisan bill out of the
house the heroes bill for another three
trillion dollars including
things like tax breaks for millionaires
and billionaires in new york and san
francisco
unrelated to the coven 19 relief bill
that we needed
so i applaud the group of bipartisan
senators who've been working
now after the election to try to come up
with the relief rather than kicking this
can down the road and leaving people
in the lurch during the christmas
holiday season
and then when it comes to a vaccine
i have no doubt that the incoming
administration is going to claim
complete credit for
producing a vaccine and getting this
virus in the rear view mirror i
understand
why they would be tempted to do so but
it is because
of the bipartisan action that congress
has taken with this administration
through operation warp speed that we've
seen
our world-class scientists come up with
safe and effective i hope soon to be
certified vaccines by the food and drug
administration
and people can begin to start getting
vaccinated
by the middle of this month that is a
modern day miracle
we should all be proud of it but it
should not be it should not be part of a
partisan campaign now after we've had an
election on november the 3rd
i wish our friends would get out of the
campaign mode and get into the governing
mode
we've got important work we need to do
here
and part of that madam president is
the jenna quinn law this bipartisan
piece of legislation that i introduced
with senator hassan
over a year and a half ago to help
identify and stop
child sexual abuse in communities across
our country has passed the senate
unanimously
but stuck in the house of
representatives
nationwide there are more than 42 000
survivors of child sexual abuse adults
now 42 million adult survivors
of child sexual abuse sadly these
victims often stay silent for days
months years even a lifetime as a result
they and countless other victims
continue
to be abused we need to stop
this cycle as quickly as possible and
that's why the jenna quinn law is so
important
it's modeled after 2009 texas law which
requires
teachers and caregivers and other adults
who work with children
receive training on how to identify
and report child sexual abuse
after the texas law passed in 2009 one
study found educators reported child
sexual abuse at a race
rate almost four times greater
after the training than they got during
their pre-training career
quinn herself tells the story of her own
mother saying if i'd just known
you were showing all the classic
symptoms of a victim of child sexual
abuse i would have intervened sooner
well the 2009 texas law was one of the
first to mandate this training
and now more than half of all the states
have adopted a form of jenna's law
so you may ask why do we need to pass a
federal law
well the states don't have the funding
for the training and that's what the
jenna quinn law provides it allows
the current department of health and
human services grant funds
to be used for this specialized training
this bill has received the support of
every member of the senate help
committee
republicans and democrats not
surprisingly
and it's passed the senate unanimously
but it's been months and we're still
waiting for the house of representatives
to act just last week
house democrats under speaker pelosi
did find time to act on a bill to
decriminalize marijuana
on a bill to deal with large cats
the tiger king bill but did they have
time to provide assistance to small
businesses
did they find time to pass bipartisan
coven 19 relief
did they find time to pass the jenna
quinn law which i'm sure have put on
their suspension calendar would pass
very quickly and go to the president for
his signature
in a move that defies common sense the
chairman of the
education and labor committee in the
house congressman bobby scott
is blocking blocking
the gina quinn law he voted to
decriminalize marijuana
he voted to ban the private ownership of
big cats
but he won't even let the jenna quinn
law receive an up or down vote on the
floor
of the house of representatives well if
you're confused by the logic
of this move you're not alone
especially because the urgency for this
legislation has only grown
during the pandemic as families have
stayed at home as part of the mitigation
efforts their lives have been filled
with a range
of new stressors loss of income
isolation health anxiety
and the stress of teaching children at
home can test even the healthiest
families and relationships
but they also put children at a higher
risk for abuse
and neglect in april this year
nationwide reports
of abuse or neglect dropped an average
of 40 percent
compared to the same time last year now
ordinarily you would say well that's
good news but the reason why
the reports of abuse and neglect have
dropped is because children have not
been going
to their classrooms where the teachers
who train in identifying
these signs and symptoms can see them
and help them by intervening
in 2018 two-thirds of the reports of
child abuse were
submitted by people who came in contact
with children as part of their jobs
i mentioned teachers counselors
caregivers but also police officers
lawyers social services but
predominantly teachers who see these
children at school
teachers education professionals and
other support staff
at schools like bus drivers are
responsible for more than half of the
reports of child abuse
but as i said with children home during
the pandemic out of sight
from their teachers and others adults
would that would they would otherwise
see on a routine basis
abuse is becoming more difficult
to identify and report not because it's
not happening
but because these children are having to
suffer
silently living with perhaps locked down
with
their abuser as the stresses of the
pandemic and the lack of reporting
take a violent toll on our children
across the country it is time
for action not excuses not
decriminalizing marijuana
not a tiger king bill
but passing legislation that will
actually make their lives better
give them some hope
not action at some time in the future
but now
and there's one person in the house of
representatives that's holding that
up right now and that's chairman scott
children are suffering every day madam
president
they're not worried about politics
or whether chairman scott has the
leverage he needs to advance a larger
partisan bill later on next year
these victims are
worried about their own safety they're
worried about how long
how much longer will it be to some adult
identifies my abuse
and gets me out of this abusive
relationship gets me out of a living
nightmare
well the sort of mindless obstruction
we're seeing
from chairman scott in the house
exemplifies everything people
loathe about congress
holding up a bill to prevent child
sexual abuse as a means to gain
political leverage for a
bigger partisan bill it's just
shameful let's call it what it is
shameful it's time for chairman scott to
stop blocking the jenna quinn law
so we can provide the life-saving
training to the men and women most
likely to stop
the cycle of child sexual abuse
and finally madam president last week
here on the senate floor i spoke
briefly about our retiring colleague
senator mike enzi from wyoming
and some wisdom he imparted to me
shortly after i arrived
in the senate something he calls the 80
20 rule
as our friend from wyoming told me
you're never going to agree
or disagree with somebody 100 of the
time but that doesn't mean you can't get
important work done
so instead of just focusing on the 20
you can't agree on
look at the 80 you can agree on
i hope all of our colleagues remember
will remember this formula for success
in the coming days as we work to deliver
another round of coronavirus relief for
the american people
it's clear we're never going to agree
100 of the time
on what that bill should look like but i
bet we can agree on 80 percent
and we ought to get that 80 percent done
we all believe that additional funding
for our schools is necessary to keep our
students and teachers healthy
and kids on track for a good education
that american workers who had the rug
pulled out from under them earlier this
year deserve
additional support that a second round
of job-saving paycheck protection
program funds would help even more
workers and small businesses
and that another investment in vaccine
distribution is
essential to bringing this pandemic
to an end last week leader mcconnell
announced progress in the negotiations
to pass another bill by the end of the
year
he's spoken with the president's team
and the speaker and
there are hopeful signs there appears to
be a path forward on this legislation
that could clear both chambers
and receive the signature of the
president and i hope we will follow
that path to a constructive conclusion
as i said last week the best christmas
present we can give the american people
would be to work together in a
bipartisan way to provide that relief
we need an outcome and to get there
it's going to take compromise it's going
to take
the 80 20 rule this process requires
input and agreement from our colleagues
in the senate the house and the white
house as does all legislation
but my constituents i dare say all
americans are
fed up with the dysfunction they see and
the partisanship that
is for no real purpose that has delayed
this coveted 19 relief
relief bill for months it's time to
reach an agreement
and deliver deliver yet another round of
coronavirus relief
for the american people
madam president senator from idaho thank
you madam president
i rise today to highlight some
meaningful progress
underway on the nez perce clearwater
national forests
to improve the health of these forests
these collaborative efforts are showing
progress and are an example
of where we could go nationally
collaboration brings results
i've see i've been a longtime champion
of collaboration to address public lands
management disputes
as collaborative processes are good for
the environment
and good for natural resource-based
economies
collaborative problem solving is a key
way to ensure that all voices are heard
and long-term solutions are crafted
working together through collaboration
does not require a sacrifice of
principles
but it does require earnest negotiations
with respect for ideas from all
perspectives
and a willingness to work to understand
each other's objectives
inevitably at several points along the
collaborative path there are strong
disagreements
however participants refusal to quit is
a key
attribute of successful collaborative
efforts
one of the greatest benefits of
collaboration is that it enables the
achievement of solutions
that are better than the status quo
for all stakeholders
such solutions are better for the
environment and the economy
through collaboration participants can
actually achieve
their objectives and in ways that
benefit
the entire community
the work on the nez perce clearwater
forest national forest is a great
example
of the benefits of collaborative efforts
the clearwater basin collaborative or
cbc as we call it which was officially
launched 12 years ago
has had an important role in furthering
discussions about the management of the
nez perce clearwater national forests
nez perce tribal representatives
representatives of federal and state
agencies
county commissioners local communities
timber companies conservation groups
and other stakeholders make up the cbc's
working group that accommodates a
diverse
array of viewpoints and objectives
i met with members of its of the
predecessor group called the
concleville collaborative and welcomed
the opportunity to be a part
of the cbc's official launch in two
thousand eight
i tracked the group's progress through
dedicating a member of my staff to being
a part of its discussions
focused on resolving long-standing
concerns
and land achieving land management
decisions and fostering communication
among different interest groups
the remarkable landscape it works to
enhance encompasses forest lands
providing habitat for trouble
for treasured wildlife and anatomous
fish species
resources for local communities
including timber
livestock grazing and mining
and natural carbon sinks that help our
planet
the nez perce clearwater national forest
span 4 million acres
three rivers flow through the forest
providing important water resources
outstanding fishing and other
recreational opportunities
it is truly a remarkable place
and the group's work is far from easy
as there is a lot at stake
the good news is that we're hearing
reports of remarkable achievements being
made on the forests the nez perce
clearwater national forest have received
three significant recognitions
this year alone that highlight
cooperative restoration work
a regional forester's award for
fostering partnership and volunteerism
a chiefs award for delivering benefits
to the public
and an undersecretary's award for
customer service for forests historic
routes projects
the historic routes projects the nez
perce clearwater national forest
dedicated
approximately one million dollars of
retained receipt from stewardship
contracts
to improve water quality through
historically sensitive maintenance along
three historic roadways
the lolo motorway the elk city wagon
road
and the magruder road that attract
visitors from all over the country
project leaders recognizing the
importance of these routes to the local
economy and historical significance
have partnered with local groups and the
university of idaho to include
digital interpretation that is
accessible even in locations without
internet
service the project has also been
supported through the secure rural
schools resource advisory committee
to assist with the maintenance
stewardship contracts have also been
used on the nez perce clearwater forest
to enable for the forest service to
accomplish vegetation and watershed
restoration
by leveraging this program with other
partnerships and funding sources
the forests are able to have a truly
integrated restoration program
stewardship contracts have enabled fuels
and weed treatment
watershed protection and restoration
road maintenance
and enhancements such as the removal of
wire fencing to help
wildlife a total of 536 miles
of streams have been restored on the nez
perce clearwater national forest
resulting in the forest being ranked
fourth nationwide in miles of streams
reso restored
the forests have a strong partnership
with the nez perce tribe
which contributes greatly to its
watershed restoration accomplishments
at the same time priorities of much
needed restoration of landscapes
including water quality improvements are
also providing
a supply of raw materials to our local
mills
in fact the forests are the fifth in the
nation in providing wood
products for purchase more work is
underway to address significant
challenges but this is the direction we
need to continue to go in delivering
long-term results
i commend all those involved in this
effort for their hard
and exemplary work improving our
treasured landscapes
also a good neighbor authority program
coordinated by the nez perce clearwater
national forest and the idaho department
of lands
was recognized with the 2017 regional
forester awards
through the program forest management
has supported fuels reduction and
watershed restoration
further the nez perce clearwater
national forest recently signed a good
neighbor authority agreement with the
idaho department of fish and game
this will enable the forest and the
idaho department of fish and game
to work more seamlessly as they
collaborate on projects to enhance
wildlife habitat
such as aspen restoration
statewide the idaho department of lands
reports the agency is utilizing good
neighbor authority to partner with
national forests in idaho
to expedite projects focused on fuels
reduction
forest health improvements and watershed
health
according to an idl summary from january
of this year the program has enabled the
treatment of 4 800 acres
through 50 service contracts at a total
value of over 3 million dollars to the
private sector
to treat weed infestation reduce fuels
complete road repairs and support
project planning and monitoring
other collaborative efforts have laid
strong groundwork
or follow in the footsteps of
collaborative work such as this
in idaho we have succeeded with public
lands projects such as the owyhee
initiative
and are hard at work in others such as
the kootenai valley resource initiative
the payette forest coalition the boise
forest
coalition and others including our
governor's
shared stewardship task force and i also
look forward
to the soon to be completed
recommendation of the governor's salmon
work group
federal policy must empower
collaboration and forest health
as senators and shared stewards of these
natural resources we must continuously
work to ensure
federal statute and policy empowers
collaborative efforts and forest health
projects in 2003 i was proud to work
with the
my congressional colleagues including
senator ron wyden of
oregon and many others to enact
the healthy forest restoration act or
hfra
to help provide the u.s forest service
with the tools needed to do the
necessary work on the ground to restore
our forest to help
and reduce the threat of a catastrophic
wildfire to our communities and
ecosystems
the hfra was designed to encourage fuel
reduction efforts
protect old growth forests enhance water
quality
promote community-based land management
and public involvement
in forest management and address insect
and disease
problems the hfra has promoted
stewardship contracting projects which
incorporate
public private partnerships emphasizing
more localized forest management
in the years since the enactment of the
hfra congress has enacted additional
legislation to advance
forced health for example in the 2014
farm bill we included permanent
authority for stewardship contracting
and the authorization of good neighbor
authority
good neighbor authority expanded the
federal government's ability to partner
with state foresters on restoration
projects
including bark beetle treatments across
state and federal boundaries
subsequently the 2018 farm bill included
an expansion of good neighbor authority
it credited the increasing the pay
credited
with increasing the pace and scale of
forest restoration projects across
idaho the 2018 farm bill also
importantly included
a 10-year reauthorization of the
collaborative forest landscape
restoration program
which has enabled the expansion of
active collaboration
and land use groups in idaho
the program encourages large scale
that's fifty thousand plus
acres collaborative science-based forest
restoration projects
in a way that encourages environmental
and economic sustainability
the u.s forest service reported that in
the first 10 years of the program
the cflrp opportunities brought together
more than 420 organizations
to engage in local collaboratives
and cflrp projects treated 3.8 million
acres
to reduce wildfire risk
the cflrp has supported collaborative
work of the clearwater basin
collaborative
and the nez perce clearwater forest to
restore conditions
within the 1.4 million acre cellway
middle fork ecosystem
through steam stream improvements the
replacement of culverts
preventing fish passage road and rail
trail maintenance and the reduction of
wildfire
fuel loads also the
authorized collaborative forest
landscape restoration program has two
newly approved projects in idaho with
one in each region
region one encompasses the panhandle
national forest
and in regional four it encompasses the
payette and boise national forests
and we can't let up in making progress
on wildfires
this severely smoke clogged sky the
severely smoked clogged skies this fire
season
made the impacts of the fires that have
decimated wild lands and communities for
years
nearly unescapable as we think about the
lives and livelihood lost to wildfires
we must continue to work to enact
bipartisan forest management reform
to build on the progress made in recent
years to ensure federal land agencies
have the tools they need
to protect communities from deadly
wildfires by improving the health of our
forests
bipartisan legislation pending in this
senate would increase the active
management of federal forests cut red
tape
reduce frivolous litigation and advance
fire risk reduction
senators steve daines of montana and
dianne feinstein of california worked
across
party lines for months to negotiate the
deal
details of the bipartisan emergency
wildfire and public safety act
enactment of sensible bipartisan
legislation such as this
which is also co-sponsored by myself and
my fellow senator
colleague from idaho jim risch can
better enable land managers to reduce
wildfire risk and respond effectively to
an increasingly virulent
wildfire reality this will build on the
successful enactment of bipartisan
legislation to enable federal agencies
to respond to wildfires
as they would to other natural disasters
and end
the practice of fire borrowing
forests make up 39 percent of the land
in my home state of idaho
they are key to air and water quality
and sustained wildlife habitat
and recreational opportunities they
support communities through wood and
paper
product jobs and recreation dollars
they are the backdrop and the means for
unparalleled quality of life
their vitality hinges on their effective
management
i'm encouraged by the achievements on
the nez perce clearwater
national forests and i urge continued
collaborative efforts to address
often contentious but natural necessary
natural resource challenges
and the enactment of federal law that
bolsters these collaborative efforts
for the betterment of all of our
communities
thank you madam president and i yield
the floor
oh marshall
madam president senator from tennessee
thank you madam president over
the past few months there are many of us
in this chamber that have taken big tech
to task
over their shady and biased business
practices
in more than one hearing we've grilled
them
on the privacy censorship and anti-trust
concerns
that have allowed us to keep these ceos
in the hot seat and that grilling has
taken place
by those of us on either side of the
aisle and these are big big
problems and they're not going to
disappear
at the end of this congress these are
problems that are going to be
around but one of the
advantages of having these companies
like facebook and twitter and google
living in our phones and
in our homes is that it's much harder
for
oppressive governments and global bad
actors to hide their crimes from the
rest of the world
just last year about this time the
freedom fighters in hong kong
this is a poster that i used on the
floor
just about this time of year december
9th
2019 and it shows the freedom fighters
in hong kong
shows how they were making their case
we do not want to become like china
these freedom fighters in hong kong
captured our attention
when they filled the streets and
demanded
an end to the chinese communist party's
terrible crackdowns on free speech
and expression and while the coverage in
the 24-hour news cycle
definitely made an impact it was the
millions of tweets and facebook posts
and videos and blog posts
that turned their movement into a
collective
global outcry for an end
to violence and terror in hong kong
you see people saw what was happening
there they saw it in real time
and even if they didn't fully understand
the politics behind these protests
they knew that the disproportionate
response by the
chinese government to stamp out these
protests
was wrong as those posts flowed
out of hong kong support flowed right
back in
and having spoken with many of these
brave activists it really meant the
world
to them that they were hearing from
us but while all of this was happening
something else some counter messaging
if you will was flowing from beijing
it was a message of total capitulation
sent by corporations sports
organizations the mainstream media
and even powerful national and world
leaders they were all trying to
keep the peace on behalf of their
own self-interest but as the days and
weeks passed by
their blinders became more and more
obvious by that time the online activist
community
had put the chinese communist party's
crimes
on full display what started as a debate
on free speech and political autonomy
morphed into a full indictment of the
chinese communist party's crimes against
humanity
against the uyghurs in xinjiang in tibet
and enter mongolia and all across
mainland china thanks to internet
freedom
efforts made possible by the open
technology fund
tweets and videos describing the chinese
communist party's
intolerance of descent
escaped the great firewall and made
its way into western news feeds
the spread of the coronavirus tore away
the veil
covering beijing's corrupt relationship
with the world health organization
and other international organizations
and revealed their scandalous cover-up
of the viruses origins all that truth
right on our phones right on
our ipads and computer screens
on every screen in the house
but unfortunately for the millions
suffering under the horrors of communism
truth didn't win the day
the people with the most
responsibilities speak up
stake silent because they were fearful
of retaliation it was too politically
charged
too economically risky someone might
take
their criticisms the wrong way and well
we can't have that now can we
i know from personal experience what
it's like to have the chinese communist
party and their
allies retaliate against you
once you speak up you're going to get it
from all sides just last week
a member of the chinese state media so
for all intents and purposes
i would suggest this is a
propaganda minister for the chinese
communist party
well he decided that he had had enough
of what we're doing here
in washington to expose chinese
aggression
and fired off a series of vile
sexist tweets while conspicuously
avoiding the issue at hand
sounds fairly familiar attack the person
attacked the messenger but the thing
is madam president he was just mirroring
the tactics used by his government
beijing is all too happy to pray upon
the ignorance
of their massive online audience and
encourage
accusations of racism or xenophobia
as the only acceptable response to
evidence
documenting their own racist
repressive politics and that right there
is how you end up with repressive
regimes
like the one in china gaining so much
power on the global stage
when those who should know better allow
their adversaries
to cow them into silence
madam president i appreciate the
importance of diplomacy
but diplomacy is meaningless without
consequences activists by their very
nature rise and fall
based on their willingness to speak
truth to power
when the most influential among us allow
evil regimes to escape those
consequences
today i call on my colleagues to follow
their example
and use their work in this chamber to
speak truth
to power about the crimes of the chinese
communist
party we no longer have any excuse
not to if you want proof pull out your
phones and listen to what activists
in hong kong and taiwan in mainland
china
are telling you or better yet listen
to what some of your colleagues are
telling you
hong kong activist joshua wong currently
sits in jail for the crime of
criticizing
his government madam president i repeat
this
hong kong activist a young
freedom fighter joshua wong
is in jail because he
criticized the chinese communist
party he criticized his government
his sentencing barely managed a blip
on the radar here another hong kong
activist jimmy ly
was denied bail during his own
prosecution specifically because
his online newspaper revealed the truths
of the chinese communist party's
chokehold on their
own people the ccp cut off
access to his corporate accounts
and those of his employees so much
for hong kong's free press
jimmy ly and joshua wong
live in hong kong in june
the senate passed a resolution
condemning
the ccp's repression of speech and
expression in hong kong
these protests are still happening
authoritarian
crackdowns are still happening
we must keep speaking about this
in xinjiang ccp forces are
systematically targeting and eliminating
the uyghur muslim population through
mass surveillance
population control and incarceration
in internment camps yes you heard me
internment camps it should make
your skin crawl to hear that today
in 2020 this is happening
last month i joined to my colleagues
senator cornyn and senator menendez
in supporting a bipartisan resolution to
finally recognize
that the chinese government is doing
and xinjiang constitutes a genocide
if you're looking for a reason to start
speaking out i can't think of a better
way to get started speak up on that
support this resolution which would not
only urge the white house to take action
against beijing but also urge national
governments and organizations to get
their heads out of the sand
and tear away piece by piece
china's disastrous influence over the
global
political economy which is highlighted
by the success of the communist party's
belt and road initiative
i will add madam president i was
thrilled today
with secretary pompeo's tweet regarding
that he is once again
re-upping the countries of concern
under the international religious
freedom act of 1998.
china is on this list
as well they should be as they continue
to
infringe on religious liberty
and they do engage in systematic ongoing
egregious religious freedom
violations they're doing it every day
and the world is watching
i would i i tell you i could monopolize
this floor for the next
week and lay out every opportunity we
have to stand up for the cause of
freedom and speak
truth to power about the crimes of the
chinese communist party here
is a white paper that i unveiled earlier
this year and there are over a hundred
specific paths
toward how we as a nation
unravel the relationship
that we have right now with china
the paper is only 52 pages long it's a
short
version and i would encourage one and
all
to take a look at it and to think about
how it is that we got to
this point where an influential
government
active in many major international
bodies
including as of next year china will be
in the u.n human rights council
how can this government perpetrate a
genocide
against minorities and get away with it
because
of the appalling cowardice of those who
bear witness
and choose to do nothing
i yelled the floor and note the absence
of the quorum
the clerk will call the rule
mr alexander
mr president the senator from wyoming is
recognized and asked that the
quorum call be waived without objection
and i'd ask unanimous consent that the
mandatory quorum
also be waived without objection
i'd ask unanimous consent to start the
vote now
without objection the clerk will report
the motion to invoke cloture
by unanimous consent such a motion
we the undersigned senators in
accordance with the provisions of rule
22 of the standing rules of the senate
to hereby move to bring to a closed
debate on the nomination
of steven sydney schwartz of virginia to
be a judge of the united states
court of federal claims signed by 17
senators
thank you the by unanimous consent the
mandatory quorum call has been waived
the question is is the sense of the
senate
that debate on the nomination of stephen
sidney schwartz of virginia
to be a judge of the united states court
of federal claims
shall be brought to a close the a's nays
are mandatory
under the rule the clerk will call the
mr alexander miss baldwin mr barrasso
mr bennett mrs blackburn mr blumenthal
mr blunt mr booker mr bozeman
mr braun
mr brown
mr burr
miss cantwell
mrs capito
mr cardin mr carver
mr casey
mr cassidy
miss collins
mr coons
mr cornyn miss cortes masto
mr cotton
mr kramer
mr crapo
mr cruz
mr daines
miss duckworth
mr durbin mr enzy
miss ernst
mrs feinstein
mrs fisher
mr gardner
mrs gillibram
mr graham
mr grassley
miss harris
miss hassan
mr hawley
mr heinrich
mrono
mr hoeven
mrs hyde smith
mr inhofe
mr johnson mr
jones
kane
mr kelly mr kennedy
mr king
miss klobuchar
mr lankford
mr leahy
mr lee
mrs leffler
mr mansion
markey
mr mcconnell
mr menendez
mr merkley
mr moran
miss murkowski
murphy
mrs murray
mr paul
mr purdue
mr peters
mr portman
mr reed
mr risch
mr roberts
mr romney
mr rosen
mr rounds mr rubio
mr sanders
mr sass
mr schatz
mr schumer
mr scott of florida mr scott of south
carolina
mrs shaheen
mr shelby
miss cinema
miss smith
miss stavenow
mr sullivan
mr tester
mr thune
mr tillis
mr toomey
mr udall
mr van hollen
mr warner
ms warren
mr whitehouse
mr wicker
mr wyden
mr young
senators voting in the affirmative
bozeman nz gardner grassley
kennedy rubio sas sullivan
senators voting in the negative can't
well kelly
markey menendez peters
shaheen stabenow udall van hollen
white house mr bennett mr bennett no
mr kramer mr kramer i
mrs hyde smith mrs hyde smith i
mr reed mr reed no miss duckworth miss
duckworth
no mr roberts mr roberts aye
mrs feinstein mrs feinstein
now
mr cotton mr cotton
mr rono miss hirono no
mr leahy mr leahy no
mr schumer mr schumer no
smith miss smith now
you
miss cortez masto miss cortez masko
no
you
mr schatz mr schatz no
mr mark me mr murphy now
small blind miss baldwin no mr crapo mr
crapo
aye
mr scott let's just go to south carolina
i
mr booker mr booker no
this is jill mrs gillibrand
no mr hawley mr hawley
aye mr tillis mr tillis i
miss ernst miss ernst i
mr casey mr casey no
mrs murray mrs murray
no
the cinema miss cinema
no mr shelby mr shelby
i
mr scott mr scott florida i
you
mr langford mr lankford aye
mr carper mr carper
no mr danes mr daines
i
mr wyden mr wyden now
mr sanders mr sanders no
mr inhofe mr inhofe i
so
mr kane mr kane no
mr rish mr rash aye
durbin mr durbin no mr wicker mr wicker
i mr merkley mr merkley
no mr mansion mr mansion
no mr young mr young aye mr romney mr
romney
aye
um
it's collins miss collins
i
miss murkowski miss murkowski aye
mr paul mr paul i
mr alexander mr alexander
i
mr warner mr warner no
mr moran mr moran
[Music]
aye
do
you
you
mr barrasso mr barrasso
mr king mr king no
mr jones mr jones no
mrs fisher mrs fisher i
mr blumenthal mr
coons now
[Music]
mr blumenthal no
mr brown mr brown no
mr cornyn aye mr dune mr boone
aye
mr burr mr burr i
it's warren miss warren
no miss hassan miss hassan
[Music]
no
mrs blackburn mrs blackburn aye
ms rosen miss rosen no
mr lee mr lee
i
mr cassidy mr cassidy i
you
you
mrs cabotel mrs capito i
mr johnson mr johnson i
jehovah mr hogan aye
mr chester mr chester no
mr portman mr portman
aye
that's clever char miss cloverchar
no
foreign
you
instagram mr graham i
mr blunt mr blunt
aye
what's mr cruz mr cruz
you
you
mr mcconnell mr mcconnell
aye mr braun mr braun
aye
um
has any senator not voted
does any senator wish to change their
vote
the a's are 48 the nays are 46 the
motion is agreed to
foreign
uh
you
you
um the senator from kansas is recognized
mr president thank you
um two weeks ago i stood in the same
position
and gave remarks to my colleagues about
the importance of
even though we can't do everything could
we do something and it seems to be too
often that in
the way the senate has operated is that
unless we can do
everything that everyone wants we do
nothing and i've
encouraged us to try to figure out what
it is we can agree on
and address that legislatively and save
the issues that we don't agree on
for later and the challenge that
uh i presented was the circumstance of
the consequences of covet 19
the difficulties that americans kansans
are facing and the importance of us
completing our work in regard to a
additional response
to try to help the economy and to make
sure people are healthy and know that
they're healthy
uh we seem to be making progress in
regard to that
desire to address the needs of americans
and so while my complaint
or concern two weeks ago was we don't
have to do everything we can do
something
it appears that we're going to do
something which is really important
now i would raise the issue of timing uh
it's very discouraging me to
to return to washington dc to learn that
the
continuing resolution which expires on
friday
is to be extended until next friday
at a time in which americans have little
ability to wait
at least to know what they're going to
be able to expect
small businesses individuals employees
employers
all need the certainty and every day
that we are unable to accomplish what we
can agree on
is another day in which those americans
those workers those business owners
don't know don't know what they face
christmas ought to be a time the holiday
season ought to be a time
for expectations and joy and comfort
uh and yet what we are doing here by
this continued
delay is creating uncertainty which
creates great
challenges the mental health and
well-being of kansas and americans is a
stake here
and again my guess is that whatever we
could
agree on next week we could agree on
this week
and so i would encourage my colleagues
and me
to redouble our efforts not only to do
what we can do
but to do it in a timely enough fashion
that people get the benefit
i think of those who work in hospitals
in kansas those who care for people who
are suffering from
the symptoms of covid
we need to make certain that we provide
them the necessary
personal protection equipment that we
need to have the necessary testing
that every hospital every clinic every
doctor has the resources necessary
to care for those who are ill today
that's something that can't wait and
when it comes to the economy
too many businesses retail
establishments motels restaurants
venues theaters the uncertainty that
we're creating by that every day goes by
in which they don't
know whether congress is going to
respond to their needs
is a day in which we may lose another
business
we may lose another person's uh
employment
and so the request is that we move more
quickly than what we have done to date
now that we seem to be zeroing in
on a compromise agreement a bipartisan
agreement
that's a piece of good news but every
day that we delay the
outcome the vote the support the
american people kansans need
is a day in which more harm is done
it is a time in which
uh uncertainty exists and uh while we
continue to have our debates and
discussions
uh that uncertainty is creating not only
economic problems but potentially loss
of life as well
this place is slow to respond and i
would encourage us to be
quicker in our response than what we
have been to date
people are struggling and they need our
help
mr president i also would say that uh
too many kansans have died people that i
know
they've died from covid this is a very
damaging disease
i would encourage kansas and americans
to do the personally responsible things
and protect themselves
to wear the mask to socially distanced
to
we do not and cannot afford another
shutdown
every day that goes by in which we're
not providing the opportunities for
businesses to stay open and employees to
be employed
particularly in rural america the places
mr president that you and i come from
we lose a business to covet that
business is
unlikely to return if we don't provide
the necessary support for
hospitals and healthcare delivery system
there isn't a hospital in kansas if it
closes its doors today because of covid
is going to open tomorrow when covet is
behind us
and the deaths that i mentioned in many
instances have been the community
leaders the people who have
made a difference in communities across
kansas and every life has
value every life has has meaning we want
this death to to end
uh and for for purposes of our economy
and purposes of life and death
it's time for the united states senate
to act
not another weak delay not another two
weeks of unknowing
but let's reach our conclusion let's
come together and find
solutions and provide hope to
my constituents in kansas yours in
arkansas and the people of america
mr president uh i yield the floor
senator from alabama is recognized thank
you mr president
one year ago yesterday
on december 6 2019
a terrorist attack on the naval air
station in pensacola
killed three american servicemen
while it is appropriate and it has been
done to honor
each of these men i rise today with a
solemn purpose of
honoring and commemorating the life
service and patriotism of one
in particular navy ensign
joshua caleb watson of enterprise
alabama
whose promising life and career were
tragically cut
short in the terrorist attack a year and
ago
yesterday caleb was posthumously honored
last friday
receiving the purple heart the ceremony
in pensacola
i really regret that i could not go that
i was unable to join his family
but there was also a wreath-laying
ceremony at building 633
where caleb was shot in the candlelight
vigil there
last night i know that bo
all were solemn occasions for the navy
for the family and for america caleb
was a rising star a recent graduate of
the naval academy
caleb had dreamed of becoming a navy
pilot and it
reported to pensacola for flight
training the week of veterans day
caleb was described as a natural leader
a person who put others first and
strived to bring out
the best in them at the naval academy
caleb was a small arms instructor
wrestling coach and captain of the rifle
team in fact
under his leadership much to the chagrin
of a couple of folks in this body like
senator reid
the academy's rifle team beat army for
the first time in a decade
ben watson caleb's father said to me
once that
caleb's mission was to confront evil
to bring the fight to them wherever
it took him he was willing to risk his
life for his country
and caleb did confront evil that day
and he made the ultimate sacrifice
unfortunately that was not how caleb
intended to serve his country
it was not what caleb's parents expected
when he joined the navy caleb's father
put it rather bluntly
we never thought he would die in florida
caleb watson was the officer on deck at
the naval air station pensacola
on the morning of december 6 2019.
consequently he was one of the first
people the shooter
encountered caleb was shot at least
five times that day but heavily
wounded he made his way out to flag down
first responders gave them an accurate
description
of the shooter that ultimately led to
the shooter being killed
unfortunately later that day caleb died
of his wounds
while in the hospital the navy conducted
an investigation into the incident
and concluded that the primary cause of
the attack
was the saudi shooter's
self-radicalization
however the report also goes on
to note numerous deficiencies in many
areas
some of which contributed to the attack
and others which could have defer
deterred the attack or mitigated the
consequences
in other words things could have been
different that day
things should have been different that
day
we lost two other young men airman mo
haytham from florida and airman
apprentice
cameron walters of georgia and 11 more
individuals were wounded mr president
that has happened
far too many times too many americans
have lost their lives to shooters on u.s
bases on u.s soil
the pensacola attack was the second
shooting at a military base
in three days on december the 3rd
2019 a shooting at the pearl harbor
harbor
naval shipyard in hawaii left two people
dead
and a third wounded there have been
several other shootings at u.s military
installations
including a mass shooting in 2009 at
fort hood
in killing texas that shooting claimed
13 lives
and left another 30 injured
five years later another shooting
happened at fort hood base
when a gunman went on a shooting spree
killing three people
and injuring 14 before killing himself
2013 12 workers at the washington navy
yard right here in our nation's capital
were killed by a military contract who
was later killed by security officials
in 2015 two military installations in
chattanooga
tennessee were attacked by a gunman who
killed four people
before he was shot by police
there have been investigative reports
about all of those shootings
and there have been recommendations
after each one of those reports
in each one of the reports and everybody
shook their head
and said we've got to do better this
can't be
uh we can't continue to allow this to
happen
but what we see from the pensacola
report that we just received just
recently
is that many of those recommendations
were never followed
especially with regard to planning
training
and assessment of response plans for
situations
just like the one that occurred in
pensacola florida
that is simply inexcusable
inexcusable we have young men and women
every year every day every week every
month
that volunteer to put their lives on the
line
for this country never dreaming
that that may be their life may be put
on the line in this within the security
of a confined of a united states
military base
on u.s soil not overseas
not as part of some overseas terrorist
attack
but right here where they should be most
secure
ben watson and his wife sheila have made
it their mission to do everything they
can to prevail
prevent losing more of our sons and
daughters in this way
i think this body ought to do the same
every year we have nominations we send
young men and women
we make nominations and we get the
appointments back
sending those young men and women to the
academies that will then go to these
bases
we have a responsibility for that as
well
as our overall responsibility to the men
and women of uni in the uniform
this year i asked for and the conference
committee
included in the final version of the
ndaa
language requiring the secretary of
defense to implement within 90 days
all applicable security and emergency
response recommendations
to protect our military installations
and language requiring the secretary of
defense
to ensure that each installation
conducts and develops a plan
to conduct live emergency response
training
with first responders at
a couple of hearings including one just
last week
i asked navy leadership an armed
services
readiness subcommittee hearing that
took place last week i asked for their
commitment
it's not the first time i'd brought it
up
but i knew it was going to be the last
hearing and i knew that this ndaa
was hopefully going to include this
language but sometimes the language is
just not enough
so i asked for their commitment
to ensure that these long overdue steps
are taken and accomplished
they of course gave me that assurances
and that commitment
you know there are thousands of
important provisions
in the ndaa that hopefully will come to
the floor
very soon but none more
none none none of those provisions
more important than those that
ensure that we do everything we can
to keep our service members and their
families who live and work on our bases
safe from attacks like these as the navy
itself said in the pensacola report
talking about security manning and a
quote from the report
the department of the navy must abandon
minimum
manning thresholds designed to protect
physical assets
and to meet ineffective response times
instead installations must be manned to
rapidly respond
with a preponderance of force at any
time
to preserve our most precious asset
our personnel increased security force
manning enables presence
deterrence assurance and enhanced
response
our most precious asset
our personnel well mr president
as a father of three and grandfather to
you i understand
how precious our children are to our
families
as a member of the armed services
committee for the past two years
i've seen firsthand how precious our men
and women in uniform
are to this country and i've seen this
body rise to the occasion
to understand our fiduciary
responsibilities
that we have to those men and women who
protect and defend us
every day i had the privilege of
visiting with some of the folks in
afghanistan and iraq
and working with many more here in the
united states
wherever they are serving we owe them
our best because we owe them our freedom
i want to thank the watson family ben
sheila their son adam for their
patriotism and supporting caleb
in his dream become a navy pilot
and i want to extend again my serious
condolences for his untimely death
with the watsons however i want to
encourage this body
to hold the navy to the commitments that
they made to me last week
and to insist that the entire department
of defense
follow its recommendations for
protecting our military installations
from within
protect them from future attacks from
within
although i'll be leaving this body in a
few weeks i urge
all of my colleagues to take up the
baton
to do our congressional oversight duty
like our lives depend on it because
their
our lives depend on it and if their
lives depend on it
our lives depend on it
everyone should take up that mantle
everyone should do all that they can
to preserve and protect
the american service men and women that
protect us
they are our most precious asset
our personnel for their sakes
and for their families let's do this
thing
let's get this ndaa passed and then hold
them to it
in this next congress mr president
thank you i yield the floor
president majority leader ash unanimous
consent that notwithstanding the
provisions of rule 22
the senate vote on the motion to invoke
cloture on the s
symington nomination at noon tomorrow
i further asked for post-cloture time
with respect to the schwartz and
symington
nominations expired 4 pm tomorrow
and the senate vote on confirmation of
the nominations
in the order listed finally if any of
the nominations are confirmed
the motions to reconsider be considered
made and laid upon the table
and the president immediately notifies
the son's action without objection
as united's consent the senate proceeded
legislative session being a period of
morning business
the senators committed to speaking for
10 minutes age without objection
nice unanimous consent senate preceded
the consideration of sres 795
submitted earlier today local report
senate resolution 795 relating to the
death of the honorable
roger william jepsen former united
states senator this
for the state of iowa
without objection the senate will
proceed to the measure
as united's consent the resolution be
agreed to the brand will be agreed to in
the motions to reconsider be considered
made and later on the table with no
intervening
action or debate without objection
ice unanimous consent the senate
proceeded immediate consideration of
calendar number
502 h.r 4761
local report calendar number 502 h.r
4761 an act to ensure u.s
customs and border protection officers
agents and other personnel have adequate
synthetic opioid detection equipment
and so forth and for other purposes
without objection the senate will
proceed to the measure as unanimous
consent the bill will be considered a
third time and passed and the motion to
reconsider be considered made
and laid upon the table without
objection as unanimous consent the
senate precedes the immediate
consideration of calendar
530 hr 5273
local report calendar number 530hr 5273
an act to require the secretary of
homeland security
to develop a plan to increase to 100
percent the rates of scanning of
commercial and passenger vehicles
entering the united states and so forth
and further purposes
without objection the senate will
proceed to the measure ash united
consent the committee reported
substitute amendment be agreed to the
bill is amended be considered read a
third time and passed the committee
reported amendment to the title be
agreed to and the motions
were considered be considered made laid
upon the table without objection
as unannounced consent the committee on
health be discharged from
further consideration of h.r 1503 and
the senate proceed to its immediate
consideration
look report h.r 1503 an act to amend the
federal
food drug and cosmetic act and so forth
them for other purposes
without objection the committee is
discharged and the senate will proceed
to the measure
as unanimous consent that the alexander
substitute amendment at the deaths we
agreed to the bill is amended to be
considered bread a third time and passed
and emotions to reconsider be considered
made and laid upon the table without
objection
and now mr edition adam since when the
senate completes his business today it
adjourn until 10 a.m tuesday december
further that fall in the prayer and
pledge the morning hour be deemed
expired the journal of proceedings to be
approved to date
time for the two leaders to reserve
their use later in the day and morning
business be closed
further following leader remarks the
senate proceed to executive session
and resume consideration of the sonic
denomination under the previous order
finale i asked that the senate recess
following the cloture vote on the
simonton nomination until 2 15
to allow for the weekly conference
meetings without objection
there's no further evidence to come
before the senate i ask that it's down
adjourned under the provisions of
srs-795 as a further mark of respect for
the late roger william jepson
former senator from iowa
under the previous order and pursuant to
senate res 795
the senate stands adjourned adjourned
until 10 a.m on tuesday
december 8th and does so as a further
mark of respect to the late roger
william jepson former senator from iowa
you